from the very beginning shocked me about
era was the fact that uh
you know
it's obviously not cheap to do this and
i asked the ceo you know how are you
gonna monetize this how are you gonna
get your roi you know make systems for
cars for quadriplegics he's like no you
don't get it uh we didn't patent any of
this technology it's completely open
source and anybody that will use this
technology to help people in any fashion
we'll just give it to them corporation
from the top down is just that way about
uh wanting to help people
improve their lives uh through
technology that's just in my mind that's
unheard of
with uh you know 30 billion tech company
publicly traded um i've just never heard
of that so from that point on i was i
was all in let's uh what do we do how do
we get how do we make this happen
[Music]
we were preparing for the 2000 season
and
and just crashed boom big
200 miles an hour back on the wall
blew apart my c3 c4
vertebrae
it was on a ventilator and
it didn't look good so
that was the racing career yeah up until
arrow arrow being a 80 year old tech
company then began the journey and so
but but at that very first meeting i
said look
this is going to take a lot of time and
energy and
it's going to be fun and whatnot but i i
have no interest in driving you know 30
40 miles an hour i've been around
indianapolis at 225 miles an hour i i
didn't really want to just go put around
you know do nothing so they took us
serious and
you know
literally less than eight months from
our first meeting they got it done yeah
it's unbelievable
so
that was just the start i mean the
beginning of a a journey now seven years
in that uh
and at that point
the first corvette we had it at
indianapolis in april for a test run i
think we went uh
about 50 miles an hour that first run
and it was scary as hell it didn't
operate very well the steering wheel was
shaking and the brakes were shuttering
and we knew we had a lot of work to do
because
the goal was one month later at the indy
500 to drive hundred miles an hour then
we went 150 and then we went 200 and we
did pikes peak hill climbing so
okay well we'll come back to some of the
sort of the evolution that took place
between then and now but i feel like
we're sitting in this car
we're surrounded by
sensors
cameras
i think we've got to talk through how
you
how you drive uh this this machine this
last version is much
as a much easier install
especially since i'm sitting on the
right-hand side it gives uh
the correct side as you say
it gives it gives a wider opportunity to
mount the cameras and there you
therefore you need less of them so we've
only got four
uh infrared cameras in front of me and
then on the glasses
there's dots
which which
the cameras you know read into and so
it's pretty simple i i just turn my head
to the left and and the car you know
turns to the left go to the right same
thing and then i've got the straw
it's a relatively standard
uh sip and puff mechanism where
i blow to go and i can suck to stop
you can reverse that if you prefer you
know things have evolved but again
you know to do the really high speed
stuff that we're doing this this this
system works remarkably well because
total redundancy and reliability and
then there's the opportunity for the
driver to take over if it needs to
but we've never had that happen
in the
traditional driver's seat
you get a little better reaction time a
little better feel for what's going on
so in the event of an emergency they
have the stock system that they could
take control with sam is fully in
control
without the ability to
grab a physical steering wheel or a
physical brake if for some reason a
battery died or the system were to fail
in any way
we still have our physical hard controls
into the car and input if at very
minimum we can depress the brake and
bring the car to a stop they just simply
grab the wheel and grab the paddles and
they take over because it's very
straightforward and they can give you
give it back to me as well
by pushing a button so um i can't
overlook the fact that we have got the
bonnet up here so what is actually in
here um so the the the big system you
see across the back that's the drive by
wire system so that's what's going to be
actually feeding the data into the the
pedals and the wheels we have the camera
computer that's processing what's coming
off the camera
we have the sip and puff board so it's a
pressure sensor
looking at the the gas and brake angles
what amazes me because i don't know
anything about
it's how quick it is and there's no lag
whatsoever it's just instantaneous so we
have had
many other people in the car
driving as though sam does and there is
a breadth of
capabilities from just human nature some
people are very good at it their brain
is very easy to switch over and learn to
drive this way whereas others they never
quite catch on in the in the time that
they're in the car
we need more than one person to do this
so we have our first go
but we also can learn and grow from
others testing the car
who otherwise aren't race aren't former
racers yeah i think we're constantly
looking at how we can simplify the
solution so it can go in more types of
vehicles
um
and
make it easier for
other people to adapt now obviously
we've been talking about this all in the
context of racing
but you are in a i think unique position
to hold a license
for road driving in in the u.s yep i
mean again
through these years we've just come up
with what's the next goal what's the
next goal what's the next goal and
through that process we said hey
wouldn't it be cool to get a driver's
license that's like a full silver moment
with all this in mind
where does this
lead you to think
the technology should and maybe is going
going next
i mean number one arrow is obviously a
leader in innovation technology
oems and that kind of thing so i think
this showcases the fact that they can
work with
all of the oems as they progress in
their search for autonomous vehicles in
that whole situation so
they can be a supplier of need for that
okay so with this in mind
sam wants to retain as much autonomy as
possible in his driving
you're sitting next to him just in case
he doesn't have control
how does that we do work with the
autonomous community a bit as you said
you know they're trying to take control
away and give it to the car itself where
we're trying to put more drivers into
the car and give more control to the
driver for me the conversation around
autonomous vehicles has been that means
to an end it's been going from a to b
it's been going to shops and actually
getting out and about and i think what
as you really nicely highlighted is that
actually for a lot of people
it's not about the a to b it's about
you want to drive
you want to race this bridge the gap
right and uh
i mean i'm i'm all for an autonomous
situation in the sense that
not everybody can afford a 60 70 80 000
minivan right for their own
transportation but i'm not the type of
guy that wants to drive with your hands
yeah um if there's an ability to go on
an app uh via voice command and call up
a vehicle that can get you to your son's
soccer game or to work or you know to
your doctor's appointment i'm all about
that i just know it's not happening
right now but i think
at least more important personally to me
is
is how can we utilize this system or an
adaptation of the system
to get people with disabilities back to
work
what are your goals in life
what do you need to accomplish then what
are the barriers is it transportation is
it mobility is it technology and and
let's break down those barriers let's
make it more cost effective
and uh and get people you know out of
the house and
back into daily life and so with our
foundation in cooperation with arrow and
everything else i mean that's really
what worked on the states is
man can we can we use this system to
drive a harvester or to drive a forklift
or something of that nature
that will help
help people get back to work that's
that's kind of my personal goal is
things are going on how do we how do we
improve lives you know i i was extremely
fortunate to have a great insurance
a really uh supportive family
the motorsports community behind me
really wasn't without anything right but
i know that's not the norm
with people with disabilities so
and amazing that you mentioned a combine
harvester i mean no no word of a lie
one of my notes in here to ask you about
was other forms of transportation that
this kind of system could help people
with yeah and i've literally written
i'll read this verbatim i'm not kidding
could the technology be put into other
cars or vehicle types such as tractors
buses or planes
now i i'm guessing
planes
may be a bit ambitious i don't know but
amazing but you mentioned something you
know and
to everybody else this advancement the
technology just kind of makes their life
easier you know
on a daily basis but for people like me
and and others
we just need a purpose with no reason to
get up you know maybe it's just as
simple as putting putting you know
getting your paycheck and putting bread
on the table but uh
man it's it's life-changing you know
i've seen it work
personally in so many occasions so
i guess if nothing else it
sort of re-inspired me the capabilities
that we have
but you'd be driving in eight months
it's just kind of like bam i mean it
can't happen if you get the right people
in the right room and the right
resources and you just
you're gonna do it you've got to set a
goal and you got to get it done and so
all of these things are just you know an
absolute dream come true and and beating
able-bodied drivers as you said like
that is that is testament to the fact
that the technology your own
determination and experience it works it
works and and i think that goes to show
maybe that the technology can be applied
effectively in
a range of of vehicles absolutely
it can be applied to like you said
airplanes and
everything else and so maybe maybe we'll
have to look at a jet next
i would i mean i've always wanted to do
an interview in a car like this i can
take that off the bucket list yeah don't
know if i'm quite brave enough to do in
a plane i'll be perfectly honest well
there's all these people going to the
moon now right or going to outer space
that could be kind of cool i would do
that i would do that yeah i might i want
to be on branson
for that yeah
well thank you so much for talking to me
it's been a great pleasure and uh what a
brilliant experience to be in here and
hear about your story from from you
this has been technically speaking and
i'm nate langston and also i don't have
a driver's license
for more content like this though follow
us on your favorite platforms